I'm video yeah that was fun oof so I
figured I should get this out the way
nice and early just so you have one less
thing to worry about this year today I
would like to explain to you why the
world is not going to end in 2012 now
the reason we even have this 2012
nonsense is that it was apparently
predicted that in May 2003 a rogue
planet called Nibiru was going to crash
into Earth and end the world which quite
clearly didn't happen and so just like
every other prediction of the end of the
world ever when we didn't die in May
2003 the apocalypse was just quietly
pushed back a bit to 2012 that's
basically a nine-year margin of error so
I don't think these people are very
exact about the dates that they pick now
the apparent reason that 2012 was picked
as the new end point for humanity is
because of something that you might
already have heard of the Mayan calendar
or specifically the Mayan Long Count
calendar just one of the many calendars
that the Maya made the Maya basically a
very old and also very cool civilization
who basically really liked time they
study the skies intricately they made
temples with architecture based on the
number of days of the year and they also
made a lot of calendars but something
the Maya didn't do at any points ever
was predict when the world would end
that's just not something the Maya did
they made calendars which ended but just
like any other calendar when one ends
you get a new one I could make a
prediction right here and now using my
copy of the official 2012 Justin Bieber
calendar I can note that the calendar
ends on the 30th of December and predict
from that that because the calendar ends
there that is also where the world must
end right really the end of the Mayan
calendar just like the end of the Justin
Bieber calendar has no real significance
unless you want to know when that
particular calendar ends although these
end of the world errs have picked their
dates specifically the 21st of December
2012 they still can't seem to decide
what catastrophe is actually going to
happen on the date that they've picked
you might remember earlier I mentioned
that planet Nibiru which is also
sometimes referred to as Planet X
which is apparently on its way to
destroy earth but it probably won't
surprise you to hear that there is no
such thing as Planet X in fact if it was
gonna hit us in December it would have
to be close enough to earth now that we
would be able to see it in the sky with
our naked eyes but we can't because it's
not there these people are also worried
about solar storm sending a scary solar
flares because solar activity is nearing
its peak and I actually can't deny that
one we will be hit by solar flares at
some point this year and they will have
a noticeable effect on our planet most
notably they'll be making some very
pretty and harmless lights in the sky
called the Northern Lights terrifying I
know one of my favorite stupid theories
though is the worry that the earth and
the Sun are going to align with the
center of the Milky Way causing
something bad to happen somehow that is
genuinely as specific as they get on
this one and they seem to think this
even though the Earth and the Sun
aligned with the center of the Milky Way
every single year and nothing ever
happens basically even these people are
stupid sorry or just baby just ignorant
I don't know but they're not the most
intelligent people in the world they're
perfectly aware that all of this 2012
stuff is nonsense and they're just using
it to sell t-shirts and books and
survival kits to people that they are
scaring Eve away they have absolutely no
evidence for any of these claims that
they're making NASA themselves have come
in and thoroughly debunked every
assertion that they've made and they are
not worth any of your time happy new
year again I hope you have a good one
and remember always deny the apocalypse
because you'll usually be right and when
you're wrong
there'll be nobody around to say I told
you so you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
just as an aside it does genuinely end
on the 30th of December this calendar
which is just wrong it's missing good
taste
that's just so bad I don't think I'm
even gonna buy a next year's Justin
Bieber calendar how'd you like that
Biebs